o agente é a todo mundo chorando todo
mundo está vendo esse barulho porque é
isso
como o cadáver de uma boa vantagem de
gols ganhar a gente começa a perceber a
energia foi mexendo palco é agora eu tô
assim embora o pará onde o pessoal vai
lá ajudar robinho você falar como é que
eu vou ficar com o rosto do primeiro eu
não sei o que fazer
bate aquele medo de fato à falha do
leblon
ela já falou pede ela estuda é uma
criança que estuda vulnerabilidade medo
coragem e vergonha
durante os anos a de trabalho dela na
área social
ela fala que a presença dela disse que o
que une as pessoas
é o que faz com que as pessoas continuam
vendas
é nessa cidade de se conectar agora quem
você olhando pra mim não é exatamente
como interessante a agência ou pelo
número não é suficiente
na sua fala
ele já tem um jogador a utilizar a linha
de inscrição
o ted não vão cair revela joaquim já
cuidou de león
já o do banheiro infantil já moramos é a
ordem
meu amigo fidel escreveu o papa o pv que
vai pedir um elefante eu colocarei o
título de economia criativa é de minas
onde viviam como a cabeça é suficiente
mas cara perguntou como é ser diferente
é como se a diferença de chance o time
brigando mais fácil
já num carro chefe
e foi o que eu fiz um bom trabalho dê
tudo certo o cara é jô não vou saber da
oportunidade que você tinha que dar
as inteligências sem saber que a gente é
assim a gente sempre fica pensando como
é que pode tudo discutiu com um marido
você pode fazer tudo certo também que
falar que se deve ou não ser suficiente
como é que eu faço nesse mesmo período o
metrô coragem para pensar fora da caixa
para ser criativo para sair dessas
bobeiras que tem aqui um novo nome
nós somos educados a pensar igual a
escola cedo para pensar igual nós é
diferente
não é assim que nós trabalhamos no dia a
dia
no dia a dia nós temos processos têm que
entregar o resultado
a nota tem que ser assim de tanto é
assim que se faz um trabalho como é que
a gente pode ser diferente na assentada
isso hora e até aqui na frente
diferentemente de vocês vocês estão aí
o objetivo é me convidou pra falar que o
euro será mais o seu desejo em ser
diferente nessa nova york também tinha a
mudança de carreira no brasil você tem
um mapa estuda desenho de 2016
são os dez segmentos que mais geraram
direção nos últimos tempos
nós vemos aqui a agricultura
nós vemos também área industrial à
fabricação de peças em engenharia
nós vemos serviços varejo nada isto é
vários segmentos está no timbu vai você
vai pensar o caminho até lá ela falou
assim sabem falar em energia limpa
também vai procurar saber da localidade
é o cenário em portugal muito positivo
muito produtiva sustentabilidade
soulja ambiental seja financeira o
brasil eu tenho aproximadamente três
milhões e meio de desempregados
não é fácil
mas a economia criativa vem na contramão
dessa tendência
a economia criativa cresceu 70% nos
últimos dez anos enquanto o brasil vivia
sua pior crise de recessão a economia
criativa perceber os pontos 6 por cento
com o clube mas o que é economia
criativa alcançada com ele já viu
conhece trabalha no velo economia
criativa é tudo aquilo que trabalha que
tem a ver que o conhecimento total ano e
criatividade
tá é eu falei com os dados econômicos
aqui em relação à economia criativa mas
betão outro aspecto fugir da economia de
star wars em se desculpar pela errada e
olha tem uma diferença é preciso
mencionar nada de um jeito que acreditar
é um pesquisador que pesquisa sobre a
criatividade você já leu o livro de onde
vêm as boas idéias super recomendo
ele estava com uma idéia vem de uma nova
conexão quando uma rede de neurônios se
forma dentro do nosso cérebro é assim
que tem uma nova idéia está sempre
trabalhando em ritmo normal de forma
nenhuma nova idéia era um dom que também
é o meu santista também fez uma pesquisa
no laboratório com os funcionários do
laboratório
nessa pesquisa ele fez o seguinte a lei
da van e filmou por um tempo novamente
todos os funcionários da assembleia
o farmacêutico que ficaram no
microscópio o cara que é alto o
bebedouro café o tempo todo ele estava
filmando na hora de fazer o relatório
deve perceber que a criatividade as
novas idéias surgiram
normalmente eu estava fazendo um
relatório estava concentrado mas no
momento que o pessoal estava no corredor
tomando água ou no cafezinho e carnês na
cervejinha depois do trabalho
quem aqui nunca teve uma boa idéia
tomando bem isso é possível notar na
internet o que deve ou cabeça pezinho
lado nem momento que a gente está
extremamente concentrado mas é no
momento que a gente está mais relaxado e
que a gente está se conectando aí daí
vem a criatividade das linhas boas
idéias
o pé peraí saber idéia do momento que eu
peguei a chave é veementemente pelo
conectando não é sozinho eu vou ter boas
idéias aqui e trouxe alguns exemplos da
economia criativa poder compartilhar com
vcs
a gente tem a como economia criativa que
mais cresce no brasil pelo mundo
nós temos bons exemplos aqui no brasil
melhores bons exemplos aqui em sorocaba
de economia criativa
tá mas temos por exemplo o rio de
janeiro tem uma cheia chamada fellype
gabriel na feira lupi essa feira é a
senhora que viveu a marca reserva foi à
feira que revelou a marca farm e foi à
feira por benê via porque é que os
fabricantes que estavam a produzir sua
roupa tinha contato direto se conectaram
direto com o seu consumidor retiraram as
suas dúvidas
podia saber como melhorar o que o
público tá querendo
sem intermediários em santa catarina
sorocaba não tem uma cultura muito forte
de cooperativas de santa catarina no sul
demais em santa catarina tem uma cheia
em que 90 artesãos
eles trabalham diariamente lá um dia por
semana uma prisão é o responsável pela
venda de todos os peritos não se o
produto que ele produziu
então o sujeito enquanto produziam tinha
alguém vendendo seus produtos
obviamente que isto foi apoiado pelo
governo da prefeitura que cedeu o
terreno e as universidades a revisitarem
auxiliado pela metodologia do negócio
está há um bom tempo vendendo produtos
com uma margem legal para eles mais
barato que o consumidor
obviamente que grandes é fabricantes não
se interessa não tem ponte interessem
pelo negócio
an mas economia criativa é não essa
feira não é só o artesanato não essa
cultura segmento de games
uma pesquisa publicada em 2015 pela lei
beach revelou que o 32 por cento entre
os jovens e 3 - e os adultos e 59 jogam
alguém anos morreu coisa no facebook
alguns joguinhos do celular você faz o
tento de sangue é o segmento com uma
apresentação absurdamente grande
quantos e quantos jogos a gente consegue
desenvolver nas nossas escolas e nas
nossas universidades para poder pilotar
em ver qual é a diferença que a gente
tem hoje o segmento de governo está
sendo discutido no ministério da cultura
recebe mais investimento mais dinheiro
do que cinema
apesar das mudanças nos últimos anos
sendo a tv paga produzirá é produzir
programas nacionais a produzir aqui no
brasil
tá então é o segmento há muito dinheiro
há bastante investimento e de uma
maneira mais sustentável insustentável
do ponto de vista econômico
insustentável do ponto de vista é de
atendimento é na nossa sociedade
não podemos esquecer também não
mencionando mas não podemos esquecer que
uma pesquisa é de uma a organização do
técnico china adote no dia 25 de
setembro tem pelo dias atrás publicou
aqui feito outro brasileiros detêm 50%
da riqueza do brasil
eles têm a mesma riqueza e 100 milhões
de brasileiros apenas oito contra seis
mulheres
nós sabemos o porquê a concentração de
renda é cada vez mais forte aqui grande
varejista comprar um pequeno registro do
supermercado acabou com um pequeno
supermercado
então pra gente é criativo não vai para
o game vai para o filme mostra o vídeo
maker bairro de tudo de uma maneira
inteligente aproveitei dele aquilo que a
gente tem nosso mercado corporativo
era um mercado diferente as coisas
ganham e ganhou exponencialmente hoje no
mercado é a riqueza não está em ter as
coisas mas está na distribuição é bem
não tenho um quarto de hotel não tem
esse poder
mas a maior reboteira do mundo ela
distribui webber não teve o carro mas é
a maior frota rede de carlos é o do
mundo está na distribuição
então tá no benitão software encher o
caba foi lançado há pouco
o aplicativo é um aplicativo chamado
time do sangue pois faz com que você
possa ajudar o banco de sangue do tipo
acaba a sua versão
se ele quiser ficar muito mais fácil
receber a ele pode te avisar com
medicação muito menos custoso para o
banco de sangue que pode também ter
menos atendente porque está todo muito
mais organizado e as inventou a um
exemplo do segmento de economia criativa
de tcheco feira essa agora em dezembro
são paulo vai ter uma filha chamada ano
criativo em homenagem aos empreendedores
criativos vai me tirar e criatividade
nessa feira 16 em números no brasil e
ser regulado pelo ministério da cultura
eu tenho e unidades em relação a isso
só aí vocês vão falar puxa a taxa de
economia criativa mas tem o bê tem coisa
compartilhada com a diferença entre
economia completa e atinge compartilhada
essa mistura não necessariamente
compartilhado é criativo é compartilhado
não necessariamente uma economia
criativa mas se você trabalhar no colete
você pode através das conexões fazer seu
produto mais criativo pelo sérvio fora
da tela taxinha daquela bela como estou
me sentindo em ser mais criativo aqui
para os mais antigos
um é o caso da maioria aqui eu não sei
quem mandou a mãe que tinha pelo produto
grande que na prática ela pensa assim e
hoje com a imagem está tão clara mas
isso aqui é um fone de ouvido tal não é
decerto praticamente antigamente
o foco para um produto hoje o foco
também na experiência do usuário
tinha um aparelho não o diz que nem
querem receber que ficar aqui
constrangido o bicho tem se está a
consolidar um computador portátil hoje
de um evento aqui em pé não tem mais a
quase não tem mais o chame externo
então é muita qualidade hoje o foco
também isso então quando a gente fala de
time do sangue que melhora a qualidade
do da do processo de doação de sangue
a gente fala de weber que melhora também
a experiência do cliente em relação ao
táxi convencional e falando comigo se
tiver um taxista
é a gente está falando da melhora da
qualidade do cliente então nesse nesse
jogo que a gente uma criatividade
experiência positiva do compartilhamento
tá aí você vai falar mas o que isso tem
a ver com a sua experiência do elefante
do euro e por que você perde um todo ter
medo de ficar aqui com a economia
criativa
essa falta que eu tirei no quem tinha
uns quatro meses atrás num congresso
sobre inovação social
a gente viu é pela biomimética os
animais nem bom primeiro menina rebeca a
outra até as missas transmitidas na casa
são sempre diferentes
mas mesmo através da diferença elas
compartilham elas se conectam
é isso que a gente faz com que o ataque
foi o que vocês viram aqui tem um
projeto que a gente faz aqui a sua acaba
com os diferentes diferentes idades
diferentes músicas diferentes
habilidades
a gente faz aqui ea gente quer fazer
economicamente na nossa sociedade
obrigado
[Aplausos]